everyone it's warrant and want to give
an official congratulations to Samuel
for being the first winner of theory
Thursdays
Samuel is 15 years old from Puerto Rico
and he won with his theory about how
Avengers in game is going to play out
Samuel is the first winner of my new
segment Theory Thursdays and he'll be
getting the prize of two imax tickets so
he can go see Avengers in game in IMAX
or whatever movie he would like to see
in IMAX for everyone else of course
Theory Thursday will still continue so
be sure to keep submitting those
theories you can send them to cosmic
Theory Thursdays at gmail.com if you
have a theory of your own every week you
will pick the theory that you like the
most to win the week and at the end of
the month out of all the theories that
one you will vote on which one you like
the most that will win the overall month
and the monthly winner will win the
prize just want to thank you all so much
for supporting this new segment that I
started and I have to say sorry because
I'm not going to be able to do a segment
today I'll be posting the complete
segment of Theory Thursday tomorrow I'm
really sick and I've already done two
videos today my voice is just shot but
don't worry I'll definitely be posting
the five submitted theories tomorrow and
you can all vote on them thank you again
so much for all your support and
congrats again to Samuel for being the
winner if you want to interfere chance
to be on a segment of Theory Thursdays
that complete instructions are in the
description down below as always thank
you all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]